Друзі, всім привіт! З ваших коментарів я зрозумів,
що ви б хотіли знати, як німці сплачують податки.
Сьогодні я приїхав до офісу штоєрбератера - радника зі сплати податків.
Спочатку пропоную дізнатися в нього,
як функціонує німецька система сплати податків.
Мене зустрічає податковий консультант Бйорн Райнгардт.
Новенький офіс щойно заселили.
Він розташований у діловому кварталі міста Ерфтштадт,
який ще активно добудовується.
У Німеччині професія податкового радника затребувана:
їх у країні, за даними самих податківців,
станом на початок 2019 року - майже сто тисяч.
У Німеччині чим більше заробляєш, тим більше платиш податків.
Податкова ставка має досить широкий діапазон:
від 14 до 45%. Важливе значення при цьому має,
зокрема, сімейний стан. Усього є шість класів
оподаткування у Німеччині, пояснює Бйорн Райнгардт.
- Перший податковий клас мають усі неодружені люди.
До другого класу відносяться батьки-одинаки.
Люди в подружжі, які мають різний заробіток,
мають право обрати між третім і п'ятим класом,
де третій - вигідніший клас оподаткування, а п'ятий - гірший.
У третьому класі податків знімають менше, у п'ятому - більше.
Подружжю, яке заробляє приблизно однаково,
найвигідніше бути обом у четвертому класі: тут
відрахування з заробітної платні схожі на перший клас.
Люди, які мають другу постійну роботу,
оподатковуються по шостому класу.
Довідник із визначення суми податків -
це "біблія" податкового радника, у якій щороку
з'являються нові правки. 1060 сторінок!
Найпривабливіше у німецьких податках те, що
частину з них можна повернути.
Для цього необхідно заповнити річну податкову декларацію.
За допомогою можна звернутися до податкового консультанта
на кшталт Бйорна. У середньому це коштуватиме 150 євро з особи.
Дешевший варіант - за 20 євро придбати
електронну програму, яка автоматично генерує
декларацію для подачі на основі внесених користувачем даних.
У будь-якому разі спробувати розібратися
в німецькій податковій системі варто, адже,
задекларувавши прибутки, можна повернути частину грошей,
навіть якщо ви найманий працівник
і здавати декларацію офіційно від вас не вимагають.
- Припустімо, один працівник заробляє 30 тисяч євро брутто на рік.
Приблизно порахуємо, що він сплатить із цієї суми
25% податків. Це 7 тисяч 500 євро.
Якщо не заповнювати податкову декларацію, все так і залишиться.
А якщо ми внесемо у декларацію 5 тисяч євро як супровідні витрати,
це знижує не лише базу оподаткування,
а й саму ставку податку з прибутку фізичних осіб.
Як наслідок сума податку становить лише 5 з половиною тисяч євро.
Таким чином, подавши річну декларацію,
людина заощадила дві тисячі євро.
Супровідними витратами на професійні потреби,
які можна частково компенсувати,  вважається
дорога до роботи, придбання комп’ютера або іншої техніки,
витрати на інтернет і телефон, спецодяг і навіть діловий обід з клієнтами.
У ФРН платники податків у середньому
можуть повернути собі близько тисячі євро на рік.
Друзі, я приїхав до органічного фермерського господарства
Bioland Luhmer. Ну що ж, давайте запитаємо
у фермерів, як вони платять податки.
Корови рідкісної породи Ґлан вільно пасуться.
25-річний фермер Себастіан Лумер о восьмій ранку
обходить усі схили, щоб перевірити, чи є у тварин
вода і трава та чи не час їх переводити на інше пасовисько.
Родина Лумерів володіє фермою вже у третьому поколінні.
- Фермерські господарства в Німеччині можуть сплачувати
або звичайний податок на додану вартість - 19%,
або спеціальний сільськогосподарський - 10,7%.
Якщо ти обираєш сплату 10,7, то це фіксована ставка.
У цьому випадку  отримані від продажу продуктів
19% ПДВ можна лишити собі, однак потім, якщо ти
щось придбаєш для ферми, податкова ці 19% тобі не компенсує.
Фермери в ФРН можуть брати кредити під 1,5% і нижче.
Влада допомагає виплатою дотацій і в випадку неврожаю
може анулювати податок на землю.
Себастіан веде до "куромобіля" - сараю для курей
із сонячними батареям і на колесах, який саме
автоматично випускає птахів на вільний випас.
- Існує можливість отримати допомогу
за програмою субсидій банку KFW,
наприклад, на будівництво сараю
чи якщо купуєш отакий вагончик для курей.
Максимальна сума - 40% від вартості покупки.
Варість такого "куромобіля" - 50 тисяч євро.
Щодня Себастіан збирає з нього близько 400 яєць.
Вартість десятка - 4 євро 80 центів.
Тут самообслуговування, тож покупці залишають гроші,
беруть здачу і забирають товар самі.
Трактор Deutz- ще один приклад, який німецький фермер наводить,
коли йдеться про вигоду від декларування й оподаткування доходів.
- Я дуже задоволений цим трактором.
Він у мене вже близько п'яти років. Тоді він
обійшовся в майже 96 тисяч євро. У рік купівлі
податкова повернула 19% його вартості, тобто ПДВ.
Друзі, я проїхав буквально три кілометри
від фермерського господарства пана Лумера і ось
тут, у районі Бонна Мелем, розташована перукарня "Anna und Che".
Ну що ж, давайте зайдемо до перукарів
і поговоримо з ними про німецькі податки.
Ця перукарня запрацювала рік тому. Аби її відкрити,
Анна три роки навчалася на перукаря, потім ще
додатково рік здобувала категорію "майстер".
Таке підвищення кваліфікації в ремісничому центрі
коштує 8 тисяч євро. Наявність серед працівників майстра -
передумова для того, щоб відкрити власну перукарню і взяти кредит.
- Дуже важливо, аби почати бізнес, мати бізнес-план.
У ньому має бути описано, як підприємство
в наступні три роки буде функціонувати, як ми його
собі уявляємо і що ми пропонуватимемо клієнтам.
Ця перукарня - з дорогих:
така дитяча стрижка коштує 25 євро.
В інших місцях Бонна можна підстригтися й за 8 євро,
однак у цій перукарні завжди людно
і черга розписана на кілька днів уперед.
- Я плачу податки як приватний підприємець,
особливого класу для нас немає.
Із річного прибутку у мене виходить десь від 25%.
Однак є випадки, коли малі підприємці працюють без ПДВ,
сплачуючи при цьому лише податок на доходи.
Зараз поясню.
Друзі, це маленьке кафе в районі Бонна Енденіх відкрили дві сестри.
Концепція закладу - домашня здорова їжа
з продукції місцевих фермерів.
Мене зустрічає одна з сестер - Зільке Луппа.
Сьогодні в меню: сирний пиріг,
шоколадно-банановий пиріг і тарт із  морквою й цибулею.
З того, що можна взяти з собою, - лікери, олія, чатні,
джеми, крем-супи в банках. Усе сестри готують самі.
- Ми займаємося цим кафе паралельно до основної роботи.
У мене і в сестри є робота, з якої ми сплачуємо
податки і страховки, і ця робота дає можливість
займатися кафе як малим бізнесом.
Це можна назвати хобі.
Воно настільки мале, що ми платимо податки
за спрощеною системою. У Німеччині встановлена межа:
з обороту до 17,5 тисяч євро на рік не стягують ПДВ.
Про обсяг обороту треба повідомляти податковій.
Друзі, ну а яке ж приватне підприємництво в Європі без українців!
Це Іван Кравченко - програміст із Харкова.
Уже 7 років він працює у Німеччині.
За цей час був найманим працівником,
потім приватним підприємцем, а згодом
заснував товариство з обмеженою відповідальністю
і сам став роботодавцем для 15 українських програмістів.
Його компанія спеціалізується
на програмному забезпеченні для безпекових систем будинків і банкінгу.
- За кожен рік я десь сплачую 35%
від свого чистого прибутку. Але якщо я тут живу,
я розумію, куди йдуть ці податки: в інфраструктуру,
у транспорт, у розвиток, у освіту.
Усе це коштує набагато менше, ніж в інших країнах.
І що теж дуже важливо:
я отримую
податки назад, які стимулюють мій власний розвиток,
тобто країна зацікавлена в тому, щоб розвивати бізнес.
Нині фахівець у галузі ІТ в Німеччині в середньому
заробляє 5000 євро на місяць до сплати податків.
Якщо цей програміст одружений і має двох дітей,
після сплати усіх внесків, податків і страхових виплат
на руках у нього залишиться 3361 євро.
Податки, за даними німецького мінфіну, становлять
близько 93% усіх надходжень до бюджету ФРН.
Офіційно в країні налічується 40 мільйонів платників податків.
це половина населення Німеччини.
Якщо ж враховувати, що подружжя за бажання
можуть декларувати податки спільно, вважаючись
одним платником, кількість осіб, які сплачують податки у ФРН, ще вища.
До речі, покарання за ухилення від сплати податків
може сягнути 10 років за ґратами,
і уникнути його не вдається навіть найбільшим улюбленцям німців.
Принаймні, це засвідчив випадок із президентом
мюнхенського футбольного клубу "Баварія".
2014 року Улі Генеса засудили до 3,5 років
позбавлення волі за ухилення від сплати податків.
Друзі, що ще ви хочете знати про Німеччину?
Пишіть у коментарях і побачите це в наступній серії!
Побачимось!